okay two people joining this livestream
this is a fairly late stage in our
molecular structure and computation
capabilities for version 12 we're
looking at documentation we're talking
about some final designer series okay so
these things there was Malec molecule
display options what is that right so
that's that'll be the option for
molecule Claud molecule plot 3d where we
would hide where we would put all of the
specific string value two options that
will in the future be what controls a
plot theme so things like I don't think
that's the right thing to do why don't
we have that BIM method option for now
okay yeah so so molecule plot 3d and
molecule plot will both take the method
and goes to and then you can give it an
association with all of these things are
like double bond offset which controls
how far apart to put the lines for
double bonds yeah I think that's the
right thing Michael do you object to
that no AC J's nobody hit this
discussion table just shove it into
method
okay great all right yeah fine
okay let's get rid of that then um so
one thing that's new there is the option
for molecule aromatic bonds it's not it
doesn't work in today's build I'm
currently making it work but the idea
there that's an option rate so because a
bond can be one of single double triple
right so atom coordinates
okay as an option right you're gonna
you're gonna do experimental eyes I mean
gee future eyes these things aren't you
so should they all be I was under the
impression you had to specifically say
that each one is good before it had to
be so that's why we have this meeting
today to clarify this yes okay all right
okay
well all right fine okay but yeah I can
do few tries them and then I don't know
why this is whether the detect bombs
what does that mean
so when you enter a molecule such as
benzene or anthracene we can either keep
it in the - for one of the two forms
with a single de alternating single and
double bonds bonds is there okay so it's
show me so if I say molecule what's the
smiles for well if you say benzene or
something right to me okay let's say you
look at its bond list they will all be
marked as aromatic so how do I get the
bundle if do I just say input form yeah
or bond list is a symbol okay fine so
what's your point so what would the it
should be right so some people might
want that to be always in the form of
alternating single of double like
localized bonds but that's not the good
option name for that I mean so it seemed
less if let's see so you might call it
techie lies which kind of means the
opposite okay hold on hold on hold on
the the name when you say include
hydrogen's
that's so for example if I would say
here that thing there include hydrogen's
are all false
well how would that affect this
structure so the input form would be
much smaller yeah but everything is okay
it's a man I think this is a similar
kind of thing and I think what it is
it's more like no magic should be may
develop right like detect aromaticity is
one one that I thought about but uh a
woman are these size spoons but why
aren't we why are we just saying include
aromatic balms because I feel like there
is a detection involved if you enter it
in as single double single double and
benzene we I would like to be able to
detect that after you enter it and
change them if the setting is set to
true so it's okay for them to aromatic
right how about a remote eyes bonds I
think it's really weird I think it
sounds I mean it sounds faintly romantic
or something I was trying to get away
from techie lies yeah that's awful too I
mean given that we're calling this
aromatic um okay so let's walk through
what this really is so what we want
um
did I write this so did you guys write
this you did initially and I've I added
structure diagram coordinates and
aromatic bonds today okay it's good by
the way too when you do add things to
put them as tentative so we know what's
out of them what's not okay okay so
let's read through this whether to
implicitly add hydrogen atoms for
unfilled balances okay so no that's not
right
explicitly specified
3d coordinates of atoms in a molecule
explicitly specify 2d coordinates to use
in diagrams because they're not real 2d
coordinates if you understand what I'm
saying
oh absolutely right yeah because those
are not really analogous right and it's
so that's why Adam coordinates will
always return a quantity array because
it they are they do have a what do you
mean by return a quantity right what are
you talking about right so it's a
Windy's so with no no no if you're gonna
do that you cannot do that you cannot
have the option also be a function right
no no that's not what I meant
the there is a property with the same
name as the applica all right okay
unless presumably a property with the
same name is this option yes okay and so
this one is in quantity array and this
one is in some kind of literal chord you
know it's some kind of just numerical
coordinates is that correct yes
okay okay so this one is so if I put in
here automatic bonds are of false what
would it do so if it was hooked up as
like it in my local build yeah I would
say single double single double yes okay
why don't you just call it use aromatic
bonds
this is the uncommon construct in our
world I know I tend to think of it as
marking them but I don't know if that's
the right kind of verb name
okay well we've got include but we don't
have from chromo how about enable
aromatic bonds
I think we use enable elsewhere in the
law yeah we do but I no I don't think
that's very good either but it's another
question of enabling it's a question of
whether okay
form how about
bond rendering rendering it's about
what's in the input formation right you
can say position I think you need
aromatic there unless other hold on are
there other things like aromatic bonds I
mean or is that chemistry is so freaking
full of these special cases okay
and are there so that's all I couldn't
that's so these are things that I need
to know when I'm constructing the
molecule and so I can't think of it
others at the moment
okay so include this is very similar to
the include hydrogen's business right
it's something that will come up in the
future will be dative bonds so we need
to come up with a way to handle both
types properly question for dative bonds
in if we're going to handle dative bonds
in the future post yeah I understand but
what will be what will be the handling
of those well they can be represented as
charge separated double bonds in
structures such as in sulfuric acid or
cellphones and but they would be
something that we would detect in the
structure that would be something that
some of the user could enter and then we
would allow them I mean we would know
what to do with that in the future but
there's this the single bond with charge
separated or double bond or dative bond
representation I I don't know what I'm
sorry yeah that's why that's why we put
it off till am but I don't I don't know
what would this then look like okay
instead of s double bond
oh it could be s with a double plus
charge to say a single bond to each
oxygen and each oxygen have a negative
charge that's one representation I see
the third representation is with a
dative bond which is rendered as a long
arrow with a cross on it basically
representing a plus sign on the air so
this is another is this another with
that
feck the internal structure of this or
not it does not affect the structure the
structure the electron positioning the
lewis dot diagram doesn't he means the
structure in the sense of molecular
arguments na it would be yes it would
not change the structure structure other
than we could use a quote dative quote
for the bond instead of quote double
quote great so it does affect the
structure yes okay so yes it does okay
language structure yes chemical
structure no in general it's something
that would have to come from outside
like they read in a mall file that has
dative bonds in it or they well Oh
couldn't we detect it can we detect this
case yes I can they are not automatic
right fine so um so that's not something
I'm familiar with any other toolkit
doing so I I let's let's clearly
possible in principle so but it's only a
matter of v1 to not need a whole bunch
of new volts for this right that's the
point
that's what I'm just saying
you know I don't like this term but
auto-detect bonds that's awful but you
get what I'm saying
but the Dada today they kind of each you
point to take right I understand
so it's localized bones localized
aromatic bonds if you want to make it
it's not aromatic specifically we're
talking but we want to combine the date
of an aromatic cases how about an option
called special bonds and the right hand
side could be aromatic data you know a
list of things to be handled in a
special way yeah we don't nothing like
that or none which means we don't do
anything okay I like that general idea
and then we could say um I mean I'm I'm
I'm favoring it's not quite the word
rendering what is the bond
interpretations yeah interpretation is
probably appropriate so interpret bonds
maybe a cue 212 about bond
interpretations because it's reflected
into the salt bond representation types
and then we can say cuz I can imagine
you're gonna want to do this for I want
this aromatic bond I've got some crazy
molecule with six you know six of those
little hexagonal thingies right but I
want one of them represented is that
could that happen one of them
represented you know aromatically and
the other dkq lized whatever the term is
I can't imagine what you would want to
know no we wouldn't do that it would be
all or none okay and I want to
re-emphasize that I don't think that
it's all that let's see I don't think
dative is something to even really
bother about at the moment it's I don't
think that this is a special case I've
been doing this for about a year in
aromatic is aromatic representation
aromatic which is and that's true or
false
you either use the aromatic
representation or you don't yeah that
works you know that'll handle this case
now and then we'll just have to deal
with something for dative bonds later
okay and if it's enough of a corner case
we can just ignore it
I mean I've come across it in the past
right and I mean generally the I don't I
so let's see if detecting and marking
bonds as dative is something we want to
do that's always something that a
molecule modify can do yeah so we'll
worry about it later okay this case here
but this is important because patterns
when doing substructure searches it's
it's all over it's very common to mark
to look at aromatic representation how
to represent
once
whether to use aromatic representation
it's that right yeah
could also be allow aromatic bonds or
include aromatic bonds
Erma what do you want to do allow our
magic bonds include aromatic bonds why
not include aromatic bonds I mean if you
don't include aromatic bonds it means
you're going
single double
and that would be very analogous to
include hydrogen's seems better to me so
I'm not really oh the bounce will be
there regardless it's a question of the
type of bond that's there I know but but
it's it's like include aromatic bonds as
opposed to use only single and double
bonds
they'll be my argument so I'm not
opposed to that it is clear what it does
okay then I prefer it include automatic
whether to
include aromatic bonds or to catalyze
that correct phrasing
usually we we say we use the calculate
form okay whether to include automatic
bonds or use calculate form but then we
did run across the the point that
there's a large percentage of the
chemistry community that doesn't even
know what that word means at all then I
think using localized bonds would be
better or localized single and double
bonds but then whether to include
aromatic bonds or use I think double
form yeah okay leave it that way that'll
that'll be fine for here okay okay so we
need to rename on that page um yeah I'm
gonna sit well I understood it's easy to
okay
you
okay alright so here I think we can
you
what are some typical plot themes that
are useful Freight so so I have only
three plot themes set up for molecule
plot 3d which are essentially the ones
that have been used in chemical data the
what of a space-filling there's ball and
stick okay specify ok specify overall
rendering overall appearance yeah so now
and i want to put in friends so to say
what some of them are space-filling so
correct yep space filling ball and stick
ball and stick like that yep you've got
so so wireframe is one isn't it yeah
wireframe okay we can do dot dot dots at
this point to just go good people some
idea those two are obviously useful I
wouldn't mind a better name for it so my
favorite plot theme I couldn't come up
with a good name for it because it's
what's called stick plot what does that
mean so it's like the ball and stick but
I take away the the balls isn't that
just wireframe no so wireframe uses line
and okay stick plot uses tubes so okay
okay well I love that and so um bond
stick
or something I mean I don't quite know
what these names are noting because that
basically space-filling is it's just the
atoms correct with Van der Waals radii
and they they look like the a bunch of
bubbles stuck together and so stick plot
is what we came up with in when we
exposed it an entity value is that the
default it's not just just for
continuity but also I'm talking with
design and weight and they might we
might just decide to to make it the
default I'm not well so let me let me
understand what this is gonna do so if I
say
okay by the way did we fix the the crazy
um spherical regions and things rate so
I wanted to verify I actually like
really liked the spherical region goes
to sphere I have not said it on molecule
plot 3d but well nobody needs to be the
men ball right not the the sphere is
being set that the issue is does furrow
no no no you misunderstand Stephon as
always okay there is a setting now for
for spherical region where you can give
it a sphere okay okay but what and what
and only this specific thing I always
must understand is more general go ahead
okay no but this particular thing has
come up in so many various I know it has
so why don't you get it once and for all
so I actually understand it so what can
happen is that graphics 3d can take an
option for spherical region that is an
actual sphere okay which just includes
all of its objects what did you have to
specify that it will just use that
sphere period
okay okay so for a function like this we
can use min ball and other things to
compute what the actual sphere is to
give it okay
that's and that's what needs to happen
from a molecule plot i-i've in my tests
I've done I really like the way that
that looks and so I just wanted to make
sure that that's a good thing for me to
do in this built-in function is just to
set it to that yeah it's still gonna be
automatic you see right so because
that's gonna be derived from data so you
can't give it a specific thing doesn't
matter okay okay so if this is not you
have not set that in this case correct
also to be clear so like the value in
the molecule proptosis automatic but in
the resulting 3d care fix its experts it
exactly okay good that we don't ever
misunderstanding no okay by the way you
gotta fix this autocomplete that all the
complete is obviously silly there's a
sticker right I'll talk with a with Tom
about how to do that for molecule plant
3d Jason do we have like a dog okay good
Jason do we have plot seems for molecule
plot the 2d version we had talked about
using different journal themes right now
I mean so I think you should go further
you know post this release should call
it careful yet you know useful okay no
big bro right so for this release the
the idea is that I will just have all of
the method options that will allow
people to make the plot themes and then
in the in the future releases we will
really make some nice ones will bundle
them okay yeah
it could be that some of them use
labeling schemes for instance and then
there you have a project to do labeling
right - right but I I could see that
people would appreciate that I've been
talking with I spoke with with men at
the conference about setting up
call-outs and and all that right before
really think about yeah I think that
would be not always but for you know
it's clearly a useful thing
we still have to talk about the molecule
am i okay great yeah so do you do we
have an opinion since we're all here
about which of those should be the
default this one okay I get to obscure
this one B but I think these names hmm
the names have continuity with chemical
data so and with with all of the import
so in the in the past you've been able
to import a I think ball-and-stick is a
good name because agree get sub olds and
sticks but they're they're used in the
field like since forever yes I know
these clinics cool pipe cleaners or
something what would it would is this
last one usually cold why I usually her
appeared as wireframe even though we're
using cylinder here with caps on the
ends so what would we call a thick wire
frame or it's not quaint but if you want
to look at wire frame it really is just
lines it's useful when you're looking at
larger structures you know maybe they're
not really because four lines you do is
most obviously defeating yes but you
might get 3d from the from the size of
the structure but extremely thin
cylinders might give you a better
feeling later yeah but I assume that
they're gonna be themes that sort of
kind of aggregate whole chains of moloch
of of atoms together hmm like you do for
proteins and other things okay look
stick plot is clearly not a winning name
because it's a different character of
name than all the others so I could
- uh - Jeremy and asked he's not going I
mean he's not gonna happen in about you
cement I just went design I'm sorry no
design is fine um I think - were
cylinder some or some name that uses
those phrases would be good for this one
how about like bond tubes was that too
utterly obscure how about cubes so just
to maybe I mean ball-and-stick is
singular mm-hmm I think it should be
tubes plural totally right it's an
adjective of form and I think this is
more unless you called it tubular
totally it reminds me of a 1970s album
about yes
great so so if someone did plot themes
and then arrow and then they had a
autocomplete for ball-and-stick or tubes
and wireframe I think it would be clear
what they yeah I think so - yeah okay
call it what since a course kinetise
formulas skeletal yeah yeah we'll leave
that for anatomy plot okay all right
let's keep going
um let's see so so the big thing that I
wanted to verify before we before Monday
is a molecule pattern of her I've heard
from many people that it's confusing
because it's not a Wolfram language
pattern and
doesn't invoke okay what is this fixed
valence thing so that would be an option
for molecule modify kind of a catch-all
if it's true then we try and do the
right thing we add hydrogen's remove
orphaned hydrogen's when you created a
bond and left them behind
if you make a if you delete a bond in an
aromatic ring I'll first convert it to
its delocalized form before doing that
okay I think it's a good concept a bad
name okay so I was using the string
valence handling goes to true or false
what why isn't this a function for other
things as well I mean why isn't it the
case that when I specify a molecule and
just here right so I'm not opposed to in
principle fixing the molecule when you
created I just don't have that
implemented yet I'm not such a big fan
of this because they are you might get
something you didn't want which and you
should get kind of rubber team what you
had isn't there a way of specifying
something I see so right now include
hydrogen's just says anyplace you've got
hanging bonds stick a hydrogen it's very
hydrogen centric is that right I mean is
that what you're saying basically right
now if you've got a bond hanging off
whereas what does this do I mean if
you've got a bond hanging off here why
doesn't it add a hydrogen because
because they did because what this is
doing is it's assuming that there are no
Newmont no new atoms is that correct
let's see so so molecule modified so
when you add a carbon atom fix valence
would tell you whether or not to include
the hydrogen's but it also tells you
when you create a bond between two atoms
that already have hydrogen that tells
you to get rid of them but some people
might want to do it all manually and be
left with an invalid valence state for
the time being in between right and the
other way of fixing them is leaving the
hydrogen's there but then changing the
charge on the heavy atom incrementing it
for example to make CH 5 plus which is a
valid
iron and a mere speck okay so fixed
valence just doesn't seem right I think
your valence handling seems like a
better idea and then you can specify a
variety of things to do um I also think
you probably need a molecular oh gosh
what what really is it what you're
really doing is you know it's Auto
repairing the molecule after you
modified it somehow right right and so
so presumably in the future we might
have a function called repair molecule
like repair mesh molecular
handling it'll make people think it's an
anti-aging serum um what does this
really do
what are the settings for this thing for
the the fixed veil so right now it's
just automatic or false okay but then
well if it were valence handling then it
presumably you could have taken
Association on the right hand side which
tells you what to do but is it just
valence so it's valence and dealing with
aromatic structures and so what I could
and removing what I call think of as
orphaned hydrogen's and so I had a
string option name called remove
orphaned hydrogen's but I think yeah
well so so look it's really just the
bonding that's being corrected it's
nothing to do with geometry maybe I
don't know because of the geometry there
are not easily implemented rules that
could be done it usually has to be
corrected with an optimization method
under some kind of force field or
molecular orbital theory to do that
correctly you know for example taking a
carbon and that's sp3 hybridized and and
making you know making one of the bonds
a double bond is now sp2 hybridized
it's got to be complainer and that's not
something that's easily handled so we
only want to handle in this scenario the
bonding formal charges and whether or
not hydrogens get added or removed and I
think I think valence is a term that's
familiar enough to two chemists and
chemistry students and you would say
that that molecule has baylin's errors
or not that's generally what they're
called valence errors yes
okay so fixed valence errors no because
you don't want to say fix that's I mean
that has multiple meanings repair I
think is probably better and if we have
a president with repair mesh know that
we're all right that will be okay
valence error handling I mean it's very
specific yeah it's fine on that then you
can give it a bunch of different options
later right um so this function has just
tons of them I'm not even sure we need
to put this ok so then where's the
method what's the method option going to
do Freight so so some of these so let's
see so in particular compute atom
coordinates takes several subjects of
options like a random seating it takes a
max attempts sub-option that options
that don't make any sense for delete
atom right so
that so this valence error handling and
method would be the only top-level
options for molecule modify I don't
think we need to UM know all right we
can we can we can list this here I guess
and to get quite is that important but
option whether to fix to balance valence
says is that right is that the right
term what do you use for the what is the
term I don't think they I don't think
balance is correct okay well to repair
valence structure repair structural
errors
how about that okay yeah okay molecule
pattern right so so we want to call this
molecule sub structure just because yeah
because it's not the the Wolfram
language pattern matcher that that does
something with it we originally are at
some point early on we had talked about
molecule expression in comparison to
string expression but I like sub
structure because it's seems we've
already got fine molecule substructure
and in the future we'll have maximum
common substructure okay but oh so let's
just think about that for a second if
this is called molecule substructure let
me remind myself what's actually in here
you can get a smart string right right
or you can give a list of atoms and
bonds I see I see so this is really okay
but you can also have blanks on now
right right and that's the thing that is
like a pattern right you can end
alternatives as well but each of these
I'm parsing them as a specific query in
my library rather than calling the the
pattern matcher to what extent
in fact just like molecule but with
pattern ization or the under I'm using
the same underlying data structure I'm
just not doing any valence checking at
all and so so therefore things you can
have a single a pattern module pattern
that consists of two aromatic atoms
bonded to each other which molecule will
reject okay but isn't it the case that
you go from molecule to molecule pattern
by changing literals to pattern objects
isn't that true potentially but they
could stay at all like fully specified
like like in the second argument of
cases can be an expert at object yeah I
understand but but I'm still trying to
understand why people have a problem
with the term molecules pattern because
the difference between this object and a
regular molecule is that this can
contain pattern pieces is that right or
that this can contain non valence
correct things which is it so it's
definitely both right it's that so we
can contain so in the pattern here you
can write atom s or atom atomic number
goes to between 11 and 15
which wouldn't make any sense when
constructing molecule
so that's not the case of it being a
valence error it's so I guess so etai is
one who mentioned that maybe I could
find something different besides pattern
and every time I've shown molecule
pattern to people they they wonder if
that's the right thing to call it and
then finally if you look at the dock
page for bond list or atom list the
second usage is bond list of mall mall
comma Pat and I feel like that has
connotations in the Wolfram language for
a documentation page when Pat is the
second argument that to a lot of people
that will imply that you need to give a
literal Wolfram language pattern which
in the case of bond lists will work but
but every expression is a blur form
language pedal every language of the
pedal okay who really objection is this
a tie objecting to the source there's
something else in the language right so
so urine has expected expressed right no
no I mean I feel like every shown it to
anybody they this is because most people
think by pet on somewhere there must be
blanket like objects writen it's more
it's closer to the the entity value like
a implicit entity class or it has a lot
in common with that with the structure
of those queries
I think of them personally as Adam as
query Adams
but that's not the right word yeah but
that's a bit sub structure doesn't
exactly capture that does it no in my
opinion not I mean a subculture Jason
and I discussion it's like in the future
we won't have a fragment and I feel like
the discussion between the sub structure
and the fragment becomes actually quite
tricky
what is the substructure vs of a
fragment also a fragment would be useful
if so it's it's a fully formed molecule
except for one dangling hair with an
attachment point and it's when you take
two of them and you want to join them
and it's very easy it could have
multiple hairs but it's jet but it's
everything is fully specified that's
there and so why is that not a sub case
of molecule so so it could it could
definitely be that we need so we don't
have a full design for the fragment you
know but pattern has things that are
ambiguous so that it can be matched
against multiple instant you know
explicit instantiation x' I personally
like molecule pattern I don't see a
problem with it I mean it seems like
this is finding a sub structure
see this returns if you said fine like a
molecule substructure and there was a
thing called molecule substructure I
would expect fine molecule substructure
to return the substructure you go what
I'm saying whereas it actually just
returns a bunch of positions right okay
so all right so yeah yeah I guess I
needed to one last time verify that
everybody's okay with calling it a
pattern it seems like it is a pattern
it's a pattern that represents a class
of molecules a class of molecular
structures I mean okay so all right so I
will refer it I to this recording fine
sorry it was strained it injects some
levity um by the way you should give an
example with a smart string here yeah um
okay all right what else do we have to
figure out here so I mean let's see
other than that the only new thing I've
added since the last time we talked I
added an operator form from molecule
contains Q seems fairly uncontroversial
to do so
I agree so if I wanted to find which
molecule
let's see I have a list of molecules and
I want to know which one is the one I'm
currently holding up so to speak that is
just I select with molecule equivalent q
is that correct yes
so molecule equivalent cute doesn't have
an operator form so you would have to
yeah although one could make it given an
operator form the only question is
whether molecule current queue would
ever want to have a multi argument form
right I did set it it doesn't say so
there right now I do have it like that
because that's what isomorphic grass
queue does to allow three graphs right
right so it's a little unfortunate that
if you want to find out which molecule
and some set I mean is it is it blind
you know is it endlessly slow but it
doesn't even go for equal yeah and
establish you don't I mean
if you want to know okay so the issue is
really molecule cases somehow but
couldn't wouldn't Monica contains Q if
this much interest said is operator
formable do the job because the seek is
contained in itself I saw you get a
couple more that you don't want okay
yeah um okay so if there were to be an
operator form of molecule equivalent Q I
might want to make it so it's set up
right now it has these string valued
same tests as an option it's not what
what are you talking about
so if you look at molecule equivalent Q
it has the option same test yeah we did
that's fine right and okay so right and
so if it only took two molecules then
that could be a third argument and you
would yeah I wouldn't worry I wouldn't
worry about that I wouldn't I wouldn't
look what I would do right now I would
disable the three argument form of this
I would just silently not deal with it
you didn't document it don't deal with
it okay um and that way we have the
possibility of changing our mind about
how this works in the future yep okay um
seems great to me anything else
for this I mean will will so there's
Oh d-did you want me to try and go
through it hold on a second let me just
look at what's colliding with here oh
this is the thing I'm not gonna do this
was about doing some tweet I'm not gonna
do it um so I feel like we've basically
we've agreed on the usage for for
everything on that page okay
and so if i defeat rise everything then
DQ a can start finding making suggesting
improvements
you've got to say are the same represent
the same not represent equivalent
molecules
reordering of atom and bond lists that
makes them the same for which they are
the same
reordering I don't know to make them the
same
you
doesn't this thing have the whole um the
whole KQ low-tech Euler nonsense
Tazewell Freight I should add a another
string argument there same test that
which will will perform the the
calculation or so so the whole point of
molecule needing to decide upon the
construction of a molecule whether
something's aromatic but then this isn't
correct if there's a real devant on bond
lists which make them the same but up to
something or other
right a by default considered equivalent
right that's the only
you're talking about that because then
this is right
see what I'm saying because this
overrides that right yes but I mean yes
oh so there needs to be some more work
here I think um yeah we know it's not
perfect yet this was mostly the function
names for before the freeze yeah okay um
okay well I think we're good there
I mean we're gonna go through and click
through some of these let's take a look
so they're obviously I'll change the
option aromatic bonds yeah it just
becomes I mean just the changes to make
that include aromatic balms and what's
the ordering of them of the options
listed here it to be I'm going to change
it to alphabetic look let me show you
the most amazing feature I'd have you
seen this
I yes there it is now it's alphabetic
it's not the most incredible you know
high-tech thing you've ever seen
no amazing palette yes it is you could
launch rockets with it it's got so many
options okay oh yeah no there's
something um Adam name I kind of put off
the discussion for that it for there for
the future be specified I don't know
what that means
oh god what a mess okay I understand
that issue um I'm good
okay it's only a potential security risk
if you actually get the atom's sorry
well it's ordered main bond order but
that could also be something other than
bond type isn't that type of an order
yeah I think that you've it I'm
remembering now you suggested type and I
went in one ear and out the other
ah so right so whether to allow a single
argument form we might need to just
disallow that so inside a molecule
pattern bond within with a single
argument I take it to be unspecified but
inside a molecule I take it to mean
single and I think that's probably too
confusing and so we should probably just
force them I don't think I don't think
you should force them to put single in
um okay that is too confusing as such
yes uh so we could just make it always
default to single and if you want and
unspecified you either write the word
unspecified or put a blank
I would say so I think that's more
reasonable okay yeah so then the last
line on that notes represents a bond
with represents a single bond
you
you
this is what you have to do right
because there
you
it can also be in in molecule pattern it
can also be a pattern such as blank
representing any possible bond type do
you want to mention that it can also be
an alternatives or is that yeah okay now
here I'm sure you want to say in this
bond thing you'll want to say include
hydrogen's is one thing that surely is
relevant here as litter
because that's that's implicit bonds
basically yeah and then and then the new
include aromatic bonds option yep
you
I also think you should mention modify
molecule here
you
yeah you got to say more in more detail
here and they include hydrogen's you've
gotta say in more detail what it
actually does what it means to you know
does it modify the structure does it not
modify the structure does it include
them in visualizations etc right I think
you also want to have I would put
molecule plots here and mark your plot
3d they seem highly relevant to this
don't they
right okay and so here's an issue so
molecule takes this include hydrogen's
and so the model when it gives you back
a molecule it either got implicit or
explicit hydrogen's now every uh every
not every function but many functions
also it makes sense for them to have the
include hydrogen's option right now
every function has this the default
setting true it could another way that
you could think about doing that is to
have molecule itself have the the option
default option of true and everything
else is automatic and everything else
just that's what I would do so that's
what Sean and QA thought that would be
less confusing I think that's the right
thing to do so that way include
hydrogen's sort of transfers over from
the original molecule so then if you do
atom count on a molecule that has
implicit hydrogen's it will only give
you the number that's in the first or
that the ones that are explicit by
default unless you unless you give atom
count but yeah unless you give a sperm
count the option include hydrogen's so I
still would like the summary box to show
so perhaps show both maybe with one
grade I don't write or something why
don't so if there were implicit
hydrogen's it would say atoms 52 comma
30 or no not comma in parentheses and
slightly grayed out beside it plus
or just plus 52 plus 30 okay well I mean
I what I would do is plus 30 with that
would be in gray and slightly smaller
rate right okay so so they and you got
that four bonds as well he'll be bonds
something plus something right right for
the atoms who would be probably plus
thirty H okay that I mean that would be
good there but for bonds just say once
you said plus thirty H it's clear what's
going on with the pluses okay then the
bonds will be just plus in Muhammad on
the live stream points out the bond
order that you can have one point five
bond order one point five for resonance
which is the aromatic case right so so
if you want to assign a numeric value
for four bonds in a like a bond weighted
adjacency matrix aromatic you assign a
value a numeric value of one and a half
so arguably when you say bond when you
give bond here you should allow those to
be 1 2 3 1 point 5 and all no no let's
let's keep two types well so it would it
would be something that just evaluate I
mean we could allow it and just evaluate
it to the yes thing that Bjorn has been
suggesting and what if somebody says one
point four five then you give an error
message well just polarization and also
if you didn't get one polarization if
you're going to do so
so polarization I think would be a
property a computed property on the bond
yeah you're not gonna you're not going
to say what the bond order is and
include some weird polarization
calculation that is affected by whether
the thing is in I don't know you know
stuck in within solution and water and
things so presumably I I'm gonna hook it
up to let a molecule pattern take a rule
base like predicates like that for bonds
also like so--you molecule pattern bond
C s comma bond length goes to you told
you I was fine for this who's right yeah
right I think in the future we should
consider having a lot I mean I don't see
why you shouldn't allow one two three
one point five here okay because we can
use it with the adjacency matrix the
weird adjacency matrix but anything else
than those values would be an error how
do you get away to digestion to matrix
so is a molecule property it's called
bond weighted adjacency matrix okay all
right fine and we should also include
quadruple and four because those are
legitimate bonds I don't think quintuple
is yet freight rate I mean I so once I
once I get a way to visualize those once
I once I make the the rendering
primitives for those and we I find some
mole files that have quadruple bonds
then possible and then I think what we
want to say here are single or maybe we
should say I'm not
correctly single-bond blood blood blood
very exciting and just say double bond
yeah whatever you get the idea oops
right you'd fill that out yeah
um okay I think I have to disappear but
I think we are in good shape here um let
me just look at your molecule now don't
look behind the screen there's nothing
to see what do you mean I read I still
have to reno name a lot of those
properties okay okay so you're gonna do
experimental eyes D future eyes these
things if we think annotate Abel is a
word we should add it to the spelling
dictionary I sent an email to T spelling
okay okay
so I think you know the most immediate
thing for us to handle here by the way
is probably getting I mean of among
other things this is linking this into
machine learning by having some default
featured you know feature extractor for
molecules I mean at the very least we
could just get the adjacency matrix
right so I actually have a few functions
that make really nice feature extractors
but I have not gone through the motions
or to make those net encoders so I don't
alright but possibly exposing them as
resource functions in the first for now
12.1 okay fine but I think it'd be nice
to just get it to do something the
machine learning stuff do something
reasonable by default with molecules
even if those things are unfinished we
did it so some already so we used to
well so my fine why don't we just
install it why don't we silently install
it so that machine learning just does
something with molecules even if we're
not yet exposing the detailed features
feature extractors right now it's going
to fail on molecules which doesn't do
anybody any good
alright listen we're gonna have go
through some more of this documentation
but I think we're in great shape here
yeah so I'll reach out to the to the
machine learning people and see what we
can hook up for twelve
let's finish just before the good stuff
beyond yes no it's as JSON this was
Jasmine I want
do you choices because I think the
wording has to change a bit okay
terrific I will push these some changes
and talk to y'all soon thank you see you
bye-bye